okay hello to people joining this live
stream we are going to be talking about
multi-computation
and support for that in modern language
and
for everybody uh let's introduce what
what it is that we are talking about
basic point is
what
normally when we do a computation an
evaluation
we have a definite evaluation sequence
and several things are true about that
evaluation sequence first of all there's
only one thread of evaluation second of
all
you're just evaluating things and
getting well okay so what what is
special maybe we should we should start
up by characterizing that
um i think i'm going to put this in
in here again
for now
you know
current
evaluation scheme
you know special what what special
features does it have
it is um
uh you know one special feature it has
is that it is primarily oriented towards
input goes to output that is it is not
dealing with you know no infinite
computations
it's only a finite computation where
we're giving um
uh so it's one thing another thing is
that it is a you know single thread of
evaluation
um
and that's you know picking a particular
uh evaluation sequence
and another thing is
it is an answers only scheme
that is there's no no tracing
of what happened in the computation
okay so
now what we're interested in is is
generalizing all three of those things
and maybe there's more am i missing
something that we're special right now
um
no i don't think so
i mean the objectives are
to deal with multiple threads of
evaluation that's the whole multi-way
system idea
to deal with
computations that might be infinite and
where we're sampling things from the
infinite computation
and which is you know closely related to
well and also things where we trace more
about what happens than we do now so for
example where we have causal information
about what had an effect on what and so
on
so does this seem and and the goal is to
have a small number
of functions that can support all of
this and we've looked at this a little
bit before
um
you know okay so actually you know
related items
related items include
a traversal order
for um
traversal order which right now is
something in trees
uh you know we've we've defined for
trees
uh you know what about map
for example what about map what about
evaluation in general
um
and the key issue there
um
is
uh
the sort of the the key issue is is um
you know we've got
two forms of recursion that we're doing
right now we are doing
uh expression recursion
and we're doing re-evaluation recursion
does that make sense to people
that is um
and what i mean by that is
that
uh you know we're both recursing through
you know we're deciding which place in
the expression do we do something at
and then once we've done something we're
deciding of the things that we just
reevaluated which one do we pick up
first
so for example here
this would be i mean this is a this is
again this is a example of a
representation
there of fibonacci right and where
what we are you know in our
model
we're doing depth first recursion you
know in our standard evaluator we are
doing um you know in this case there
isn't much expression of recursion is
there no there is some because there's
the five you know f of five plus f of
six
and we have to recurse into that looking
at the f of five first and the f of six
first and so on
okay so that's one thing that's related
so another thing related is um
uh
you know find shortest path
uh the the dynamic version of fine
shortest path aka the thing i've written
and other people have written find
replace path that is you know what one
might call virtual path finding
and what i mean by that is
you know if you have an explicit graph
that's sitting in front of you and you
want to find a path in it that's one
thing but virtual path finding is you
didn't actually construct the whole
graph but you want to you know you want
to find something from that and that is
related also to find equational proof
um
etc and for example stuff that we've
been doing for this metamathematics
project
has
uh we've really turned so find equation
of proof is almost like
uh sort of virtual
pathfinding um in a multi-way system
although it works in a slightly
different way at the end because of this
resolution theorem proving idea
yes
so i mean for example we could say
um you know to give an example of this
we could say find equational proof
um
of uh
um
what's a good example we could do let's
do something not super complicated well
the only one i ever remember is this one
um
actually let's let's just for fun
i'm just going to use because i think it
might let's just see whether that does
anything different
oh my gosh that was only 76 steps okay
so then now we say proof object to token
event graph
okay
well that was a little hard to read but
this is
this is showing
uh
roger for example do you understand what
this is
yeah i think so
can you highlight what those rings are
they probably tell what you use to get
to the next step right exactly exactly
so these are this is what this is a
substitution step this is what nick and
we are calling by substitution
which is a which is sometimes related to
what in theorem improving tech you know
communities sometimes called
paramodulation or it's a generalized so
one of the issues here that's coming up
for this is the notion of
uh you know two-way patterns
that's a that's a related um concept
here
is um
uh
but so this is an example of virtual
path finding right that is there were
you know there is an if there's a graph
from the theorem proving you know
there's a there's a graph that the axiom
system implies but we're not finding all
of it we're just finding this virtual
path
um and uh
let's see um
oh i was about to write something else
down here well anyway
um
okay in tree traversal order i want to
remind people we just introduced with
named traversal orders
right and you know okay so another
related item is the long time and very
unsuccessful trace function
which was an attempt to do this this
thing here no tracing of what happened
right it was an attempt to say what
actually because like things like
replace i suppose it's also related to
the things we're talking about yesterday
which is this um uh position applied
and um
uh etc that is when you know where when
you're using map for example
you know we have map index but you could
say something like map position applied
um of f comma
um and then
this
uh would
also pull in
as a second argument to the thing that
you're feeding into f it would pull in
the position okay
and that's um
all right so anyway those are some
related things
uh is there anything else that's
obviously related that i should have oh
another thing that's related is
probabilistic programming
uh and monte carlo
and
what roger what do you think i mean what
are things related to that you think
might be relevant here
well that you i mean something that
looks similar to this is that you um
you can do basically random path
sampling
probabilistic programming in monte carlo
okay
right
right i mean chemical reaction networks
that's another use case we have here
um
and uh okay so we've also got sort of
examples that we've done so far
um
you know of which the combinators work
with one example where you know this has
been studied decently the mental
mathematics thing is another example
where we're studying this in some detail
i'm really making use of all of these
things i've also got these things like
this
you know multi-computation with numbers
where i looked at this um anyway so that
that's that's a bit of an introduction
what are we trying to achieve oh here
here we've also got got some comments
um
right oh yeah another one i wanted to
mention was beam search there's another
example of a type of
thing which is sort of related to this
that that's that comes into the virtual
pathfinding area i believe
um
okay so what is our objective of all of
this the objective and also sorry we
should also mentioned you know logic
programming is related to all of this
etc
the objective is small number of
powerful functions that just do this
so
nick has a function here
which
apparently does a bunch of this
actually you know
functions we have
so one thing we have is um
uh
which is unfortunately way too super of
a function
is multi-way system
what is multi-way aggregation system why
is that even in there
do we really have that
last time i looked like during the
summer school i think they had like uh
there's multi-way system and then
there's like five other multi-way ca
multi-ua aggregation system multi-way
etc functions
i'm not sure which one is like the newer
one i think the single multi-way
function is
well i didn't even remember that that um
yes yeah i think that
look this the multi-way function
i didn't remember we had this at all
my gosh
um
okay where do we have this
yeah there are a bunch of i mean do we
think concurrent programming in the core
language is part of what we want to
achieve yes
because eventually you know the first
thing we're going to do is just
implement this sequentially but the goal
ultimately would be to have something
where this could actually be where we
have a clean enough formalism that
through the compiler and so on we can
actually do things genuinely in parallel
you know
being able to do that is very dependent
i think on um
uh
um what am i trying to say on on
uh
um
you know and having the cleanest
possible formulas because you know the
pie calculus is of this world and so on
are just too complicated we don't care
people don't understand them
you know this is okay so let's see we
also i don't know what the relationship
i mean petri nats are another related
thing here
and we've got
you know we've got all the
non-deterministic turing machines and so
on so we've got
okay what are we going to look at here
there's a lot of multi-way things here
uh okay probably that the main one is
multi-way system
so just to give a sense of what's here
okay so multi-way system
there's like what system are you
operating on and there are a few we've
supported here
and
in the end
we have this notion of state evolution
function state equivalence function
so the equivalence function has to do
with when you merge branches
the state event function has to do with
what are the events that will be
causally connected to other events
uh right so these this is sort of a
decomposition of what we're thinking
about in terms of the different pieces
oh by the way another thing we should
list here is breadth first search
which is a function which i consider to
be way too complicated i mean i've
essentially never used it because it's
just i just you know i mean this is
about first scan rather
right so the problem with brett who who
has used that first scan
i think i've used it once i think
they're both depth first scan and
breadth for scan
are too complicated i agree
right you have a very limited subset of
its capabilities
sorry
yeah i mean they're they're too general
is it they think that you i think
they're just i think it's the same issue
as a multi-system i think they have the
same design problem basically
because i think this whole thing
about
you know this is very similar to the
problem of evaluation fronts and so on i
think it is
and and how do i think most people most
people don't need this this level of
generality
well i agree but i think it's a
packaging yeah i think it's bad but we
all agree it's bad packaging
um
but ian how does this relate to tree
traversal order
so
there's two separate functions for graph
to give breadth first in depth first but
in tree traversal order
it's just an option for tree map
and how much do you cover
for trees
what breadth first scan so breadth first
scan is for a general graph
yes how much of this
already shows up for trees and how much
of it is specific to graphs
i mean how much of it i mean how much of
all this stuff could you
argue how general are grafts well i
think they don't know trees right with
these is that it has like
a distinction between visitation and
discovery and the potential of things
being rediscovered and revisited
okay i think neither of those
distinctions are relevant for trees
i see
um
has
discovery plus visiting okay so because
you're saying in a tree
by the time you're there and and
potentially revisiting
yeah i mean in a tree it's it's
you know you go through it once
right
um
i don't know whether
somebody wants to come out from physics
project point of view i think
that when you don't if you okay if you
have a post set you don't have a closed
timeline curve i don't think you do
revisiting no it's if if the thing if
there's a partial order there's no
revisiting is that true
yes
that's a dag so right okay
so
um
by the way this reminds me of two other
things which should be here which is you
know we don't have
a you know a dag data structure do we
do we have that you mean are the actual
data structures or do you mean just
anywhere
i mean you have great we have graphs i
mean like like they're functions like
i mean their functions like what
topological sort basically takes a
a dag right and it just takes it as a
graph
yes
i don't even know what type what does
topological sort do
it's a linear order compatible with a
partial order
well
i had no idea we even had this what is
it i mean
oh i see it is a particular
order so in other words topological sort
should have
i see topological sort
in a sense should be the thing that is
fed
you know
this effectively should have
lots of evaluation order control
one could
i mean or this in fact is the
quintessential
uh you know foliation control you know
foliation
um
let me show you one other thing which is
i mean this that's a place where one
could if we had a foliate a method of
describing foliations reference frames
orderings this would be a place it
should be fed into let me let me show
you something which i've probably shown
but by the way though i mean about
having a dag data structure i mean i
think that i i don't think that would
really make much sense because i mean
the only reason we have trees is because
trees are like
trees are like really different from
graphs and like the applications are
really different okay but but i think
dags there's a
like
there's a lot more overlap with graphs
i don't know you know
we don't want to have i feel like it's
one of these things we don't want to
have you know there's there's graph and
there's tree and there's dag and there's
directed graph and there's undirected
graph and there's you know blah blah
blah what about in the data structures
area i mean it doesn't make sense any
sense there there must be i think that
for data structures i mean i feel like
for it to be consistent there has to be
an actual like data structure that's
like here's an efficient way of
representing a dag and i'm not sure such
a thing i mean there probably is some
efficient way of doing it but
like i'm not sure there's a standard
data structure for that
i mean internal uses of dags is pretty
extensive of course
um
you know in the implementing the system
well but that's a good reason to expose
it in the data structure project i mean
are there so roger when when we're
implementing dags
is there one representation are there
many representations
many
so you implemented probably maybe even
you yourself
um
you know for expressions
uh
where we basically uh reuse
um
pointers
yes no
share whatever you know
yes
okay um so there's one what do you use
the data structure is compatible with
everybody else's i doubt it i think it's
like some custom thing in there probably
yes
bdds which is a way to implement boolean
functions completely relies on a very
efficient dag
uh structure
right
what do we do so so
but that that is its own thing there's a
lot of things that go into sort of
getting efficiency in that structure
that cannot you know
and it's not exposed either it's not
exposed at all so because we we can we
can convert to bdds can't we yeah
but what does it even mean how do what
do we how do we give the output as bdt
no we get a boolean function we don't
have bdds we have boolean function
as a boolean function is free to use
other representations too right because
it's an abstract representation as long
as it performs what a boolean function
should be i didn't know i didn't know it
could have stuff inside it that isn't
just a straight table
so you're telling me that that
no a straight table is like no no it's a
table for boolean functions it's like
that's
maybe 50 years ago or something but no
that's not what i mean like if you have
if you have a you know 25 input boolean
function it better not have a table on
it no right well fair enough but but
then
so so
what is the boolean decision tree and
how do we represent that
so if i say for example
um
boolean function
well hold on doesn't boolean convert it
always returns some sort of uh
it always just returns like a boolean
expression doesn't it like it returns
just like ands and ors and stuff
or boolean this thing gave you a bunch
of other potential outputs
right but so this is if i say boolean
decision tree
is that is that just a representation
like
a um is that like a dnf or something or
is that a
is that if i say expression
tree
of this
oh is that deeper than a
yeah
because it's a boolean decision tree and
not you know
some disjunctive conjunctive normal form
i didn't know we could do these how long
we've been able to do these
well look at when the date it was
introduced
2008
hmm
but so what can it do then i mean how
good is it at doing multi-level
uh
logic optimization
well
so
well it's very good depends on what your
goal is but it's optimal so given a
variable ordering
you can compute the optimal dag to
represent it
so
another way to see a bdd is that you use
common sub-expression elimination and so
you give names to those subtrees and
that's why you get the dag inside of a
tree
right you give names to those
and
given that ordering you will
you we always compute the optimal one so
that's the min absolutely minimal dag
so what but here's the thing to remember
you know with n variables there are n
factorial possible orderings
yes so
if you change the ordering you might get
something that's dramatically smaller or
bigger
okay but so for example if i go ahead
out of curiosity i mean does that i mean
right now it's generating this minimal
dag using what ands and bands ors and
nots can you is there some way
you know of getting it to use other
other connectives or i mean does the
algorithm even work if you use other
connectives
well bdd is defined in terms of ands and
ors and not
there's something called bmds that i
kind of worked on before which is
basically using xor and ands
and in some cases like for instance if
you want to verify
an arithmetic logic unit of a
microprocessor that's a lot of variables
right 64 bit in for each of the
variables in 128 out and you know so
it's about 200 variables easily
and to represent that thing so but but
also it's proven that
that a multiplier there is no possible
way to give an efficient bmd
representation of a multiplier
but there is a very efficient bmd
representation that uses basically xor
which is mod 2
you know multiplication
but but like i'm just wondering are the
algorithms that do this are they like
pretty much like the fact that it uses
xor and is like super hard coded into
the way it works yes yes it is
but so the one that we have is using and
and or is that correct
yeah
um we could have one that used different
functions
yeah
i don't think i've ever seen this before
that that's the
those would claim to be the minimum and
or arbitrary depth trees is that correct
for that variable order yeah
wow didn't know that was possible all
right well learn something new every day
um
i do i learn i mean no no no the depth
is always the same
so the depth is always the number of
variables
you don't count not as a as a level you
don't
know the convention is that you don't
treat not as a thing
okay so
um so that then there are sort of n
variables the depth is always in
i mean you
this these things seem to have
so that's how we and that's how we
that's our expressions right this is the
point is underlying
there if if there was an option for
expression graph so that basically
identical sub-expressions got merged
then those become dags
yes
right so the dags were expanded out into
trees because you can't have
an expression that on the top level
looks like a dag
but also yeah go ahead but but but also
the the thing is like knot is treated as
a
you know if you look at the tree that
they seem to add a level yes
okay and they you know
it depends on how you define what what
abstraction you use for tree or attack
right you know is that a level or isn't
it
okay let's come back over here to i was
looking at um
in this case this is um
uh
and by the way when we say two level
boolean minimization we don't count not
as a level
yes only and and or
right
okay so here
um
this is basically foliation
foliationology
uh
okay reminder so this is
you know this is defining a partial
order
and then i'm thinking of foliage when
you say that like green trees and stuff
no what we what we're talking about here
is
anti-chains and post sets okay we're
talking about
ways in which you can define slices
where you eventually visit every node
see this is a total order right but you
can also just say
which of these things can be
simultaneous so to speak
does that make sense yeah right so here
these can be simultaneous
because they're not time-like connected
um
and you know this is an enumeration of
possible total orders
um you know
notably
our tree traversal order
certainly doesn't cover all of this
because we're only naming particular
tree traversal orders
um now so the question is what's the
sort of general case of how do you
specify
a useful traversal order
does that make sense
i mean
you know clearly you can give a
traversal by just saying visit nodes one
seven five eight four and so on but if
this was if i was going to go further
down in this i would like something
which is a a general formalism for how
to specify traversal orders
anybody know any any any approach to
doing this
i mean of of um
what it also reminds me of is
is is out of order so so for instance
and sometimes you don't want the
complete order you just want the partial
order
but i mean a total order but the partial
order so for instance in gruben bases
there are these exponent vectors they
look kind of like your thing there
you know in 2d
and the question is what order do you
visit those exponent vectors
and that needs to be a total order
and it needs to be compatible with the
the way you multiply monomials so which
is vector addition basically
but that is relevant for i mean that's
the same thing as the kluth bendix
question yes yes yes i mean yeah
yeah which is the same basis is is
knuth bendix
and grobner basis is one in the same
algorithm at some level
yes
but i mean the the
the issue
um
the issue here
this is also related to the theorem
proven question google stat is knew
appendix right i'm very linking appendix
right
um
okay
all right
i mean what's interesting about this at
a meta level is how many things that we
care about are sort of the same problem
showing up in different forms
but i did want to mention here wherever
it was
multi-race system okay
the the huge mess of different things
that you can generate from the multi-way
system
so look at all that stuff
which includes things like knuthbendix
completion rules and things
and you know part of our goal here
is to clean all this up
and just for people who are not involved
with us
um i just the the tour of basic things
that we have here
um
god there's so much stuff i mean there's
there's some
yeah i mean so
okay so multiplayer system of let's say
a string multi-base system
i mean one thing that's that's
interesting in all these cases is to be
in some ways efficient
um
yes
so
uh you know like there are many ways to
compute grammar basis there are many
ways to do pinoffendick's completion
and
and some things are dramatically more
efficient than other ways
and but the thing is that
you know like with naive search
you you can't try them all like like you
know like i said the bdd there are n
factorial orders for grobner basis
they're n factorial variable orders but
then there's a whole tower of additional
types of orders you can have on top of
that
right and i assume similar things happen
in equation uh in equational theorem
you know it is
you know so what can you afford to do it
has to basically be heuristic it cannot
exhaustibly try things well i i know but
you are talking about the old paradigm
for computation where basically you want
one answer
and i agree there are a lot of things
which are naturally stated
multi-computationally
where the thing you want out is one
answer like one path basically
but but you want the efficient one you
don't want to slow absolutely yes yes
yes yes i mean that
and that's where i was talking about
this virtual pathfinding problem
you want to efficiently and virtually
find the shortest path
right
um
and that i think is kind of crucial that
that's sort of efficient because that's
like dramatic
i know
i know i mean but that's why
that's why they're improving methods
um
although
there is this frustration with theorem
proving
that
um
okay in this proof
okay
in the end
we will prove a tautology
here
the the structure of these proofs
is you feed in the hypotheses and the
axioms
and you eventually transform
those two
into a tautology
which is not the way around that you
would do a standard pure path finding
right like if i'm trying to prove
in this axiom system here
if i'm trying to prove that a b is equal
to bb baa
i want to just find a straight path from
one to the other but in traditional
theorem proving for reasons i'm still
not completely clear on and maybe
somebody here can can
uh tell me
you know
what traditional theorem proving does
well i mean
essentially what it's trying to do is
it's trying to find a path to something
and it's easier to find a path to a
tautology
than it is to find a path to an
arbitrarily specified object
that seems to be the point anybody fill
that in and explain i mean is that a
is that a story of how why the you know
that completion algorithms
are optimized for finding a way to get
to a tautology
basically well nick has a nice
explanation of this i think so yeah
not all of them
doing that kind of proof some of them
like do refutation when they try
to prove
basically
your negation given negation of your
hypothesis
okay something something like any
contradiction
so what do you think you're saying some
theorem provers do that and some do the
thing that we're seeing of peruvian
tautology is that what you're saying yes
some of them are also like
use modal theory
to improve the search and so on
all
many strategies
well can we enumerate these a little bit
because this is
i mean
yeah i mean okay but but you're saying
well okay is there any standard strategy
that actually gets whose destiny you
know where it's finding a path from bbb
to baa and so on
or do they all
involve
introducing you know do they all have
logic assumed basically
well
most of them i think i'm not i'm not
sure maybe there is the most efficient
certainty you have logic assumed and
tried to do refutation proof
of this tautology proof
thing right
okay so i mean
when we're talking about
uh wherever we listed it
um
you know so you're saying automatically
they're improving has
uh you know
assumes logic
you know proves tautologies
refutations
and then there's the additional thing of
of you know
use model theory
as as a speed up
and presumably there are other speed ups
as well and the things that i think i
think xerxes was looking at with
jonathan and so on was um this proof to
proof transformation
you want to say anything about that
at success point we were kind of just
using very generic category theory ideas
we weren't necessarily projecting onto
some model but indeed you could uh the
model theory side would be basically the
semantics of what we are doing
but so the concept though
would be
take a proof like this
and then imagine in a sort of higher
category of fashion that you can
transform this proof this path and
quotes into another path
right
and
and that's yet a different methodology i
mean did did you have practical do you
have practical examples of
uh
no no we we didn't really go into any
practical examples we were just we were
just trying to point out the the generic
methodology
from the homotopy type point of view
but uh
okay
okay
all right well anyway so this so look
uh just i i just wanted to review for a
second what
okay for people okay this is the basic
states graph okay people understand
uh
i mean i'm going to pick on other people
like ian for example do you understand
what's going on here
yep
okay
um all right so then
then we've got the concept of a let me
give you another concept the concept of
branchial graph
okay that is
the graph of common ancestry now this
generalizes to a branchial hypograph and
and i guess nick is using this idea
of
not a single foliation a single layer
branchial graph but the set of all
ancestral relationships in the whole
multi-way graph is that right nick
yeah right if you
if you have a foliation then you can
produce like
branch of graph which way
or pair of wires
but if you don't you may as well just
combine them
that will represent like
some kind of branch or graph for all the
formulations possible but so your
branchio graph function for instance
is um if i just take this whole graph
i can feed it and this is an example of
a type of you know operation right i can
feed it this thing and it will just give
me
this which is
so that's the complete branchial graph
for all
for ancestral relationship between all
elements here is that correct
i mean it didn't there was no foliation
down here i simply look at
two elements here and i ask do they have
a common ancestor is that right
yeah and those weekly components uh
maybe in this case i can at least
represent those layers
right one of the components that graph
above indeed but that won't in general
be true that's a specific feature of
this particular rule i suspect
yeah probably
okay so i mean this is an example you're
referring to an immediate ancestor right
yes in this case
right i mean you can have a you could
have a multi-level branchial graph but
that's going to give a hypograph not an
ordinary graph
because well i mean you could make an
ordinary graph why can't you just say
join as a graph things which have a
common ancestor
you know at most two steps in the past
why doesn't that
it's the same as
getting a hyper graph and then
converting it to a graph
there's just multiple multiple ways you
can do it
well the hyper graph is
because you can have in general
when you go to
why do you need a hypograph when you go
two steps back
so let's take bba for example
what's the hypergraph that connects
these things here based on their common
ancestry in bba
well i think you have to like
take your sink first think vertex that
would be you're the first element in the
hyper edge and then you just step back
go backwards into your ancestry
right and just produce a hyperage this
way
i'm not
could you say that again i don't quite
understand that well if you open the
branch of hypergraph resource function
documentation there is like a simple
example
oh yeah i've seen this example before
yeah
yeah
are we able to do that if i just did
this thing
for a few steps let me just make one of
these
okay so now if i say
bronchial hypograph of this
does that mean
is that maybe i should run another
couple of steps
okay but these are all graph elements is
that not correct
yeah
in this case
yeah this is just edges
these things here are just edges so if i
if i just say
graph of rule
that's what i'm getting
but so what would it take to have a
hyper graph in here
i guess like this time like
like in the first example
damn
abcd
i see some it's something related to the
fact that there is a time-like
element there i'm not completely getting
it but anyway the the real point here
is
to just
say that there are these different kinds
of graphs so this is the states graph
there is a
[Music]
is it the case that the branchial graph
that the edges are edges between
siblings
and yes
envision having edges between first
cousins or edges between second cousins
exactly so that's what you mean
yes
that's what we mean
so for example you can presumably make a
branch of graph for a tree
and what is the branch of graph for a
tree it's it's a um
let's see if we if we pick
a um
okay so there's a random tree
so now presumably what we would do here
is we would say a
tree graph
of that
and now we would say branchial graph
of this won't you just have some
fragments yeah
right right because each one of those is
each fragment there
is a set of siblings
right why is there a
oh i see that that this like that
cluster there
i'm i'm a little confused so those two
will be connected by an edge
and then
well like this thing here
is this complete graph right
i imagine so those four leaves together
yeah yes i mentioned so but also the
four
children at level one
yes
right
right
but have you seen this i mean in terms
of triology have you seen such graphs
being made
or
roger have you seen these for any other
purpose
these kinds
what do you use them for i mean i i
don't get it
uh why why do you want them
they're maps of quantum entanglements
i mean they are because we believe that
because the whole point is we think that
the different paths here are actually
parts of history no i i got it okay but
but
they have other apps i was thinking of
it though
i would like it entangled in something
else than
that you mean you mean in a different
field yes well i mean for example for
example i was looking at this for games
okay okay
so this this represents
the possible configurations of a game at
a certain step
and this is essentially saying you know
okay another another application is in
mathematics we're asking you know how do
you lay out all the theorems
you know you're generating theorems from
a particular exomatic theory
and you've got them all they were
generated in some way of you know
applying axioms and so on how are the
theorems related to each other
that's a place where the branch of graph
in a sense as a way of reconstructing
the space of theorems
did that make sense
maybe
it's kind of like because two theorems
are nearby if they have a common
ancestor i see
yeah is it worth showing an example like
with a with a token event graph
uh
of what which one
we just use a token event graph to show
how we use it in meta mathematics
well here's his one i just happened to
have on myself oh okay might not be the
most fine
okay
that's one for boolean algebra it's a
piece of boolean algebra and that is
actually that's no that's the multi-way
graph and there probably is well we can
then make the branch aircraft from this
um
hold on so for trees everything has
you know everything is connected because
everything has a common ancestor
eventually yes the question these are
one level
okay the the generic branchial graph
that we're using is a one-level branch
show graph
so
everything has a the question is which
things are connected in one step common
ancestry so share a parent okay yes
your siblings
indeed yeah i think it's zero cousins
first cousins second cousins as you go
up
further
right yeah yes that's a good actually we
could have we could have called it
cousin
uh we we should have we should use like
the cousin graph of a dag
right
there
um
graph
oh yeah right
there is that a thing a sibling graph is
that a thing at least for a dag it could
be defined
i understand but it's not a well-known
uh thing
all right so anyway so these different
okay there's also this notion
of a token event graph so this this
version of a multi-way system has the
property these are events
that has the property that you start
with one state and you can get multiple
states from it
in the general case you can also have
something where you have multiple states
that are being picked up
and or multiple tokens that are being
picked up these these states can have
multiple tokens in them
so for example the the um
what is a good example of this where we
can uh i mean the string is almost like
that if you think of them as each letter
being a token
yeah that's correct but we can we can
have a more general token event graph
uh well here was let's pick up the um
um where is it
um
okay so these are these are token okay
these are token event graphs where a
single token is turning to m plus one
and plus two there's got to be ones
there's got to be an example here where
it's not just a single
token
um i mean we could clearly do one here
where
so this
okay that's just single tokens but now
what's a good example of two tokens so
we could say
nm
goes to n plus m
i don't know
abs of n minus m
okay so what that should do
let's see we're starting off from
let's start off from the state one one
it's rather boring
but let's say
okay so what's happening here at every
event
two tokens are being picked up and
combined in the event which is then
emitting two other tokens
that make sense
and in the case of a string
we can think of each event
is
taking a subpart of the string wherever
we had that up here it's taking a sub
part of the string as indicated like
this
and doing something to it so we could we
could as well represent this as a token
event graph where the individual tokens
are just elements of the string there's
an additional weird constraint in the
string that the tokens occur
sequentially in some way
but again we could just pick up
individual two tokens here and there
they will turn into in this case bbe
goes to a two tokens will turn into one
in that case
doesn't make sense to people
so in other words there's tokens you
know states are made of tokens
and
uh you know that that's that's where
in our multi-way graph formalism
the um
that's uh
what is it the state i forget what this
thing's called
um
how do you get the graph without the
events
you can use remove events
yeah but we don't have a great way to do
that we don't have a great way to do
that i mean this particular one here
um
there wasn't like already a name for
this graph
no because we we've studied a lot the
graph with states if if if we think of
this as being a multi-way graph
on individual on integers then the
integers are the states
okay
but when we do this with hypergraphs for
example the tokens
are the hyper edges and the states are
the hyper graphs
and so the token event graph
for hyper edges
for hypergraphs i think nick had an
example here
um
yeah so this is
a
oh wow that's cool
okay so that's that's one of our sort of
physics project type things
where it says this is a hyper graph
where we're picking up
pairs of hyper edges
that have that relationship and we're
creating new
so i mean for example i'm sure if we
just do two steps here
oops what happened
three
steps
uh something seems to have gone wrong
here
did i do this wrong
next there seems to be a problem here
can i try restating what you just said
see if i understand yes yes um
so
the tokens are the vertices in the hyper
edges and the states are like a complete
hyper edge
no that's not correct
okay
so the tokens are hyper edges and the
states are hyper graphs
okay
and
the
atoms
are yet a different kind of construct
they are elements
in our physics metamath project we're
calling them eems
um
they're the sort of lowest they're atoms
of existence so to speak
um
and uh let me see if i can find a good
example here
um
let's see
uh
oh gosh these are incomprehensible
um
here's an example okay
so this is a multi-way graph based on
uh complete hyper graphs right so the
hyper graphs are the states here
and every transition represents some
update on that state
producing another hyper graph and the
state to hyper graphs
we could fragment this
into into a token event graph
by saying let's just look at the
individual hyper edges here which is
much more efficient because for example
those three graphs share many hyper
edges
okay the disadvantage is that if you
fragment the thing into hyperedges
you've got this big mass of tokens but
you don't know how the tokens are
arranged into states
that make sense
um i think so
okay
i think we've we're now ready to look at
nick's function
um unless anybody has any further i mean
the main point i'm making is that there
are lots of these graphs that seem very
natural that occur in lots of different
places i mean we could also describe how
these relate to petronets
um that's yet a separate issue of um
so petrinet
is something very much like this except
that it is a i think jonathan is calling
them capacitated multi-way graphs
where
you are using up
well patriots call them tokens but we
have to call them something different
um where as you
let's see maybe there's an example here
anybody else want to fill in what what
the story is though
nick did you understand the petrinet
story
well
if that normal petrinets i can explain
that so you have tokens
you know and you can make a transition
you have transition nodes and you have
nodes
and when you make a transition that
token moves through the transition to
the nodes on the other
side bit like this yes
you know so those squares look like
transitions and those round things look
like notes
and the black things looks like tokens
right
right
anyway it's another connection here okay
let's look at next
thing okay which is now
multi-replace
uh where is it here we go
okay
so i mean again the main point of all of
this is how do we unify
all these different things we've got a
bunch of functions that do
you know
a bunch of related things how do we
unify all of this
okay let's look at multi-replace nick
would you like to give us a tour of
multi-replace
sure it's
well the goal is like to combine all
those replace functions
when you're not certain where you want
replacement to happen
and how
right
so just provides you the list of all
possible replacements
and it works for tuple subsets
and when it's not
just a list but actually different
positions on your expression so you can
act
as a tuple replacement subset
replacements a different position of
your expressions
and you can splice your result back
isn't there something like a similar
function called um
we added it's not too long ago it's not
replace all it's all frequency replace
replace that
replace list
yes right exactly so replace the list
let's look at the difference here
because this is relevant okay so
let's say we say x blank blank y blank
blank
arrow
you know f of x f of y
i have an example there is like in
relations
okay
okay so that's what that does but one
thing it doesn't do is it doesn't tell
you what it did
exactly
yes and and
nix seems to do that
right okay so nick is showing us here
let's look at this for a second
okay so you say
that's the replace list version
and that's now your version here
what the heck did this do
it is
not just
uh
like
fix the position like if your first
request list acted only on at the root
position
but you could also like
try the same operation on the position
two
that's why there are two elements there
okay but if i if i try
this case that i was doing up here
so
oh my gosh what the heck is this
what is this
maybe try level one
just
try with like range three or something
is that is that the right level
specification
oh my gosh does it have a heads option
yes it's false
okay what the heck did this do
so why did it give so many more cases
than than replace list
what is it doing that replace list isn't
doing
it consider sold possible
also oh well in this case it also like
your left hand side
right
list of x and y
it tries to find the positions for
independently for x and y there
i see so it doesn't because it is icy
because it's keeping track of what the
replacements were it cares whether x is
bound to something or y is bound to
something is that correct
yeah
so
i see so that okay so again this is this
is what happens if you trace more
um
okay so maybe we need to try an even
simpler case
um and
it's taking its time
okay so one one
means
that
i don't understand how could it get a
single f here
i don't understand this is says
x blank y blank is this
well that's how it works
x and y
in this case are both at the first
position
so tony can insert a spot because
because it's assuming that this is a sub
this is a
it's assuming the list is a sequence
it's it's assuming that a list is a flat
object
it's assuming it's like a tuple
by which you mean that the list is
effectively flat so it's deleting
duplicates
like it's like f of one f of one two
three but you don't have both f of ones
no it's binding both x and y
no actually i'm totally confused i don't
understand that first chance some of
them have two f's and some have one
yes what is that first transformation is
that okay what could i do
on range of three what replace at could
i do on range of three to get me that
first thing
that first result
is it true
we don't have a i mean replace part
or or map at rather is is there a map
out of replace
that will give me that first
transformation
oh yeah just you just ignore
the last
dude
your output contains two
elements you just ignore the last one
i'm confused so if i if i take this and
i say replace that
and i take the replacement
is this is this completely wrong what
i'm about to do it's going to apply it
you just want to do x blank goes to f of
x
yeah but why do i do what why is that
related to this
why is that doing the same go ahead
this was like an option
i've decided it has defaulted actually
on a tuple so you can multiply each of
your
sub expressions
as many times as you like because you
specified your left hand side with two
elements
so you're asking for all the sub
expressions at least
up to two times
okay looking like a single one
so it gets multiplied so you just
yeah we had a name for that option what
is it the um
subset's true
then it gonna ignore those cases
okay has subsets so so this is saying
for example in my
you know in the token event graph up
here
there's the question of whether
if in in this case here
could it pick up so let's say that my
initial condition
is just one here
will there some things simply not fire
do we have an option to token event
graph that makes it fire in this case
can you update your i think you have a
node token one graph can you resource
updated it should be one one two version
that's why your buff example didn't work
with the hyper edges
one one two
okay
i see so what that's doing there is it's
picking up that token
more than once
okay
okay but
so the basic idea here
explain okay so
multi-replace
is producing this thing which has a list
of for each so how does it know
that one of these is x and one of them
is y this this is the part number of the
binding for the first variable is that
correct
yeah this isn't the order you specified
it so the first one would be always x
and the second one y
okay but so so then in some sense what
we might be doing here
unfortunately i mean this is again it's
a thing we haven't done with patterns
right we we don't have a mechanism
we don't have a function
that specifies pattern bindings
as such in other words if you say
given
you know in this case here
given that this
you know is matching
against
i don't know what uh you know one two
three four then we don't have a way of
saying x
is
in this case probably the sequence
you know one two or something can't you
just say x colon pattern sequence one
two
what are you saying x
x colon pattern sequence of one two
o
isn't this like subset replace
no but what christopher is implying is
something very interesting which is that
we can treat colon
like an equation
i hadn't thought of that
so so what you're saying is if i say f
of x blank
and i want to match that's a very good
idea and i'm i'm saying you know let's
say it's it's match list or something
and we say match this against f six
what you're saying is that could return
this
as a representation of that match
uh well that
that wasn't what i was saying but sure
maybe it could
that's very interesting because i mean
then nick could return here something
much less obscure he could return
something that says
um
x
well it's actually again a little i mean
if you if you have variables and values
for them though i think
rules are much more
standard
yeah so i i usually like it as an
association this is what my
unifiers usually produce when you
my keys of an initiation are just
pattern variables
that's why
it's very convenient because you don't
have to
wrap with those patterns with vibrating
you can
act with those associations as for
replaceable for example
and then you can actually replace your
patterns as verbatim
can you give an example
well try like if you have a f of x blank
and try to replace that x bank vibrating
with something
right
no i'm asking how do you want to do it
yeah if i say verbatim of x blank
goes to
something else that's one way to do it
we just cannot
make an association
when you have x blank as your key that
also works
so that's how i present substitutions
usually
for for variables
so you're saying if i say that what are
you
what's the idea are you saying that i
can then say something like um
f x blank slash dot this does that work
yeah
oh
that that's something which might have
been thought to be a bug but it's
actually a feature yeah
that's that's kind of a region one
right okay so what you're saying is
because this is this comes into the
category of knowing what you did
and this so what you're saying is you
have a way to represent the bindings
of pattern variables
now we also need a way to know
you know
when you're doing evaluation what part
of the expression in addition to the
binding of the pattern variables
which part of the expression did those
pattern variables come from
which is what you're doing here
is that correct
right
i mean it's worth remembering that when
we do find equational proof
that it has this very
uh grotesque in a sense way
to i mean it did the best it could so to
speak
as a way to um
uh
let's look at a random proof object here
now slightly more complicated example
uh where's the more complicated example
help
give me a more complicated example
oh for goodness sake you know we should
fix these examples these are
ridiculously over-complicated
ridiculously over-complicated
yeah
yeah
okay in any case yeah but the point that
i'm making is
oh my gosh okay there's one that's at
least somewhat smaller
and by the way also this should use
or whatever
that is a misfeature of the fact that it
doesn't um
okay
this is kind of grotesque
oops
okay so let's look at this
okay so the issue here is
we've got all of this construct
orientation
and then it's got it's specifying where
i mean all this stuff
right and we so nick do you feel that
you have a cleaner version of how to do
this
in your world what would these steps in
the equation of theorem prover look like
yeah like critical paleo might say but
by substitution it also requires just
orientation and the position
but so do you have an example can you
show an example of where you're doing
that
you have you have your function for by
substitution right
well much replace also have a method now
okay well let me see it so what what can
you show an example
from the once you place the
communication you can
try
to find one
maybe
maybe in options method
okay so i want to for other people's
benefit i mean this took me a long time
to understand nick
figured out okay so substitution
everybody understands substitution you
take something like let's look at a
specific example
how do we make this be less long
okay
so
this is going to be substitution that is
f of y blank b goes to c what is the the
one doing level one
okay so this is now saying f of y blank
and b
which is matching this
goes to c why did it not match this
yeah there's no b there okay now this is
to be compared to
co-substitution
in which
it can
i'm now confused about what's happening
well now you can
do the unification only at the second
position
now you do it in the other direction
unify x blanket b
and your y blank is matching vibrating
right so in this in this role
here we're dealing with something which
we've never really had before which is
things like
f of x blank y blank and then we've got
a rule
is it a two-way rule or what is it does
it not need to be a two-way rule
no
just a regular
it's just the
but it can have a pattern it can have
patterns on the right-hand side yeah
that's the point
and so what we're doing is
we're saying
we can match both this both from left to
right
where we would normally have
we match the name so in a sense
a rule that
okay
if there are no blanks on the right-hand
side
it's still the case that co-substitution
can do different things from
substitution is that a true statement
even if there are no blanks on the right
hand side yes because because what
you're saying is
you're matching
is
we didn't in this case in this case it
matched the x blank against the b
correct
so it unified what it did was normally
the rule of pattern matching is you take
the thing you're matching to
and you see whether the expression
matches that
in the case of co-substitution
you're able to take the thing that you
are
matching which is itself a pattern
and you can instantiate part of that
pattern to match it
with the thing that you are
the rule you're going to apply
does that make sense roger others
are you understanding this um
what's going on here you you should also
notice that
at the
third position x is changed because of
this unification
right because x blank was bound to be
by
in order to make this a plausible match
you had to do the matching on the thing
you were
how do you i mean this is such an
obscure area you know it really needs
better names for things i mean i think
the term cost
is actually a good name go ahead
isn't it unified at two terms so you
have f of a comma x blank
and f of y blank comma b
and you want to
you want to unify
yes that's right
because that's what we call match in the
normal sense right or maybe we want to
generalize what matches i'm not sure
right i'm not sure we do so i mean maybe
we need do you have a function
sort of a unification of
f of a blank
a x blank
f of i mean this seems like it's the
core operation here these two things
yeah by those so
go ahead roman roman
roman has written several such things
over the years
we don't have one
i don't know of a place where we use
this right now but
right we should contact roman about that
he's probably got it in his books
actually yeah probably but but i can't
run i think he wrote sort of tmj
articles about it and other things let's
look it up
okay but so nick do you have
yeah i have this
is it does it have a name that we could
so we could actually use it
i just called it unify
yeah
okay it's inside of the definition
somewhere it's not maybe it's in your
mathematics yeah
should i specified it differently
yeah i think you should
reverse it
your arguments i have a unifier which is
like acts as a most general unifier
that goes in both directions
why does the same message by meters
that's really weird i'd probably
substitute it somewhere
that's probably where the where's where
the pattern magic happened was inside
the message
anyway so okay so this should have
worked and it would have then told me
that
what would have told me that why blank
is i don't know how would it specify the
answer
right but all the things that can be
variables right which we use blanks for
right are the things that need
a value a substitution yes that's
correct which could be with another
variable
right
i guess
uh
yes that's important because
even in this example here
weren't we binding
um
isn't that for ordinary substitution you
bind
named patterns on the right and for
co-substitution you bind them on the
left and unify is like doing both
something like that is correct i think
i mean
the term we're now using for the for the
two-way thing is by substitution
my god this is obscure
but by substitution is what is needed to
get things like critical pair lemmas
automatic theorem proving that a first
statement
yes
it's like substitution is ordinary match
q co-substitution is like match q but
you pay attention to the patterns on the
left
and by substitution is a match queue
where you pay attention to
patterns in both arguments yes but
apparently it's more than that there are
cases where which where are more than
just
the um kind of both way things
but i mean so
go ahead
it is both ways
no i understand but aren't there things
where where
if you are doing that on a complicated
expression there is
one part of it can be going left and the
other part of it can be going right
well yeah basically this example are you
looking at the third position
that's how it happens because one of the
arguments goes one way another one goes
another way
okay that's the point
like substitution plus cos substitution
doesn't equal by substitution
okay
okay but so
what we're trying to understand here i
mean
okay
let's look at some objectives so first
of all nick do you think that you have
if if you were designing proof data set
today with what we now know about by
substitution and so on what would you
write for all of this stuff
yeah i i i have an idea
i have a function that actually makes
a proof object
like this from the token graph
which is different from your
proof object
to
no you've got proof object to token
event graph but you say you've also got
token event graph to proof
yeah a specific token on a graph which
is the result of our
what's called accumulative token on
graph when you have statements as your
tokens
if you
if you produce a cumulative token on
graphic statements you can make a proof
object when i populate all those fields
but
my way
some of them are kind of dummy results
just to make it consistent
okay but the one of the important things
is that that you know for example this
thing is not readily appliable
and and so you've got a version of this
which is a more computable way of
specifying what transformation to make
and where is that right
well more computable is all you need is
just like a position
that's what all your your keys are in
multiple place for example
that's all you need
in order to reproduce your result
don't you need to know like the
orientation and so on well and that's if
you have a two-way rule sure
okay okay
okay but but so
so you're saying that
a proof
could just be a series of replace parts
or map hats rather
replace parts basically
yeah
just that
this is some kind of bike replace parts
replace ads because you have to unify
both way at some position
and then substitute into whole
expression to make it to make sense of
it
okay so you're saying there because this
is another issue is the plugging in
so you what we're trying to do here
we've got
okay we've got these various moving
parts we've got
we can we make a substitution we make a
transformation the transformation is
embedded within a bigger
environment and
it has to be re-plumbed back into the
bigger environment after the
transformation has occurred
that's one thing
and the other thing is there might be
multiple transformations which could
occur
is that a fair
i mean and and what we're trying to do
is represent
um
i mean
and then we're trying to figure out
for those things
what is the result we're trying to i
mean so so for example
with multi-replace can you imagine that
there's a find multi-replace path
is that the concept that you would let's
say we're trying to
get you know we're trying to do theorem
proving is there improving basically
find multi-replace path
exactly yeah find replace path
function it's just a series of by
substitutions
in some way
right but the thing is that i mean
in
okay so find replace path
but the whole point is that that one of
the issues that we had in find replace
path i think i have a version of that
maybe other people have versions of it
now too
um
like i'm not sure if this is the um
uh which version or anything this is
but wow what the heck is that
now i'm totally confused
okay i'm totally confused by what's here
some walking material okay fine fine but
i mean the find replace path that i had
in mind
was something
where okay so the version that i had at
one point
had different things it could return it
could return the pure path
but
you know you know does it return
just the path
or also
uh you know
how the steps were taken in the path
okay so so in in a
sense okay so find replace path
okay
what is replace repeated
is isn't replace find replace path is
related to replace repeated more so than
to replace so replace repeated is like
um
is like a
a single path
a single virtual you know single path
that
that
figures out for itself where it's going
so the point about find replace path is
you specify an end point and find
replace path
the different kind of computation that
is more like our usual computation is a
find replace path with no endpoint
specified
because that's the case where you're
just generating a multi-way graph
and
you know so find replace path is the
case okay so
find replace path
you know
you know the end point you know the
start and end
you want to find how to get there
and multi-way system is more like
uh
you know the start
you generate a structure
okay there's an intermediate case here
which would be find
uh
um let's see find um
uh
replace best or something
um
you have a criterion
and you want to find
the best end point you can
subject to that criterion
that's the intermediate case right the
the find replace path you've pinned the
two ends
find replace what's the right name for
this
i don't know find what maybe find or
place best as an option to find or place
path like what are you optimizing for
no
that's a different thing okay so
there's a thing here you can pick
uh different paths
you know optimizing for different things
in the path
eg path length
eg
you know eg size of intermediate
expressions or anything right
but this is a different thing this is
you don't know where you're going so
this will be things like
uh you know find um
what's a good example of this it's like
a you know like a game where you say
find
you know find the closest packing
is that a good example i don't know find
the
find the the the best contract the
closest packed configuration
where you have many pods you can go i
mean that's that's more like
these various reinforcement learning-ish
type things
it's more like active classification
how does this relate to actual
classification
anybody
christopher roger anybody i mean what
you know because active classification
is basically saying
you
make moves from one place to another
is so what i'm saying i mean
maybe this isn't it's not quite the same
thing but it's related isn't it
have i lost everybody here
or is this not making any sense
finder place best seems related to beam
search
oh yeah it might be
and i had actually
somebody had whose was this
oh this is machine learning people
have a beam search okay let's review
beam search for a second
okay is this the quintessential beam
search picture
oh my gosh this is yet another thing
isn't it i mean
so
my understanding is that this is like a
breath first search where you have
control while you're doing it so that
you're trying to find the optimal path
for something
rather than just going through the whole
tree
but what is your objective or you don't
you don't know what the end point is
going to be you're trying to get to that
one end point
no but but do you know the end point no
i think you find only enough
probabilities you just fall
probabilities maybe sample your
each step
okay
but so what what's a typical use case
for this
this is used in i mean i know it's used
in natural language processing but i'm
not sure
uh
yet different people we should have had
in this meeting okay
um
okay so this is related again to beam
search
okay but but so
you know what we're understanding is
that nick is providing the low-level
kind of
okay so here's here's a question
what your function is pure structure
looks only at structure that is if i had
an arithmetic operation going to the
right hand side here
that is not something you can deal with
because to be able to deal with that you
would have to be able to do things like
convert that operation from
understanding correctly to do
unification you'd have to be able to do
that
yeah well yeah
those are just inward
expressions
saying inert expressions right
deals with
structural transformations
on inert expressions
which is already very useful but my
question is
what
okay so again we could write
the whole of our language in principle
doing that thinking about ourselves as
doing that but in fact we have all kinds
of actual computational operations
and
is it the case that
i mean
how should we relate these things in the
case of multi-way graphs it's not
difficult to have a multi-way graph
where
oh i don't know you know like for
example
um if i do a token event graph
um
actually if i just do a multi-way graph
multi-way
see this is a hope no no let's not do
this let's do
okay so nest graph is deeply related to
multi-way graphs
yet another connection that we haven't
we haven't really brought out here so if
i say nest graph
of what am i doing i'm saying like x
blank goes to divisors of x
i say actually what i want to do is i
just want to say x
those two
is this right divisors of x
and then i say starting from like 6
going five steps
yes that's already doing that
okay so nest graph again
is yet another
function deeply related to all of this
except that nest graph which we should
have put up at the top here
nest graph again doesn't record what
it's doing
am i making sense
yeah
next graph tagged
can record
right so okay so so it's the which again
relates so nest graph
is um
uh
you know can do can make a multi-way
graph
but doesn't tag things correctly
but by the way it's worth realizing that
nest graph is a super convenient way to
make a multi-way graph
the other thing it doesn't do
is it doesn't plus
it can't make
token event graphs because it's always
got one input
right so
anyway down here
all right so you you say if we say
tagged
if we have the resource function tagged
token event graph
what is it called tags
that's called
i'm not sure we're going to see anything
different here are we
oh we are it's different colors
okay so what is that graph in fact
inside
is that graph got um
is that graph got tagged edges is that
how it works
yeah
you can
you can make make tags yourself if you
your output is a rule
it basically indicates your custom tag
by default is just
an index of your results right because
okay
for each
so you're saying that each step
it's the index number the tag is the
index number
of that edge
in all the edges produced at that step
yeah
but okay so so what this doesn't do
is to capture
let's see this is this is taking a whole
function it's applying this whole
function x goes to whatever to whatever
you have
as opposed to your multi-replace thing
which is going in and finding a place to
do the replacement
as opposed to gulping the whole thing
and just producing an output
multi-replace is going in and finding
places that match
so there seem to be these two different
i mean just as we have in the main
system
we've got two different ways to take
inputs one is by applying functions and
the other is by doing rule applying
rules
i think
so
in the case of applying a function
there's no analog of this whole
unification business is that correct
there might be some weird analog of that
with lambdas and bound variables and so
on
is there
i think so yeah
function is like a rule when you don't
have any conditions of your left
right so this is an again an operation
that we've never had as unification
can also
imagine actually we have had this issue
imagine unification with functions
um so for example what that is is for
example even in the very basic case
function x x plus one
is that equal to function y y plus one
right and the answer is not going to say
it's equal but that will be the analog
of saying
is that is that the analog i mean you
see that that's like saying x blank
equals y blank which we don't consider
to be true right now
is that right that those two things are
analogous
isn't the point that a function is
always going to apply
and the reason you have unification for
patterns is you're trying to decide
if things apply
like partial functions
well we don't have partial functions do
we
we have rules
i know but those are not functions
i mean we have rules but but but well
except they're not we don't
treat them i mean look in the case of
nest graph the left hand side of a nest
the first argument of an s graph is
something of this form which can apply
to anything
we have long discussed the possibility
of having uh
function functions
that have rules in that that have
patterns in their first argument
in which case then it's the same thing
as replacements
i mean a pattern
you know that function is just like
replace
uh like an anonymous form of down values
of like a thing with down values almost
i i think that's right yeah that that
would be right yes an anonymous down
value object yeah that's an interesting
concept
christopher have we run across that that
isn't that something that you've needed
in the compiler
um
i
don't
think so
i'm not sure i haven't really i haven't
really seen much the down value
compilation stuff
okay but i mean because this is like the
right-hand side of a down values if you
say down values of f you get a structure
and that structure is like an anonymous
down value object
well the reason that you don't need it
is because you have replace i usually
use replace as my
head for
this kind of anonymous down value
because it's just
the same thing
right
right but although it has its failure
case is a little weird i mean it's it's
when it is a partial function and the
partial function
um
okay so what you're saying is if i say
replace x blank goes to x plus 1
and i just apply that to something i'll
get that which is very nice
but now if i say x blank integer
and apply this to pi
what
why did that work didn't do a
replacement
oh it didn't do the replacement
oh
which is different than if you like
defined f of x blank is x plus one and
then do f of pi you get f of pi
right so the bug in this case says
if it doesn't do it
the function just evaporates
if you look at what down values actually
returns you know the left-hand sides
will include the f
yes it replaces the whole expression
right so
i see
maybe it would be beneficial to have a
version of this when you
have
a firework case when
the application
right where it doesn't evaluate
yeah
right
i mean the failure case for replace
definitely shouldn't should no no no
version
where failure case does not evaluate
but what you're saying is that down
values if i define
um
well you're saying that the analog of
the down values thing would really be f
of x blank
integer or just f of x blank
goes to x plus one
and then i apply that to g of x g of
seven
wait you mean f of seven no i meant g of
seven because then it doesn't do
anything and that's the exact answer
what down values does
which is sure or if you said f
underscore integer
or f f of x underscore integer and then
you said f of seven point two
then you'd get back f of 7.2
right which is not bad behavior
yeah
you know i think i haven't really
thought about these things since we made
replace
have that
sub value you know operator form
because that's pretty nice that that way
of thinking about it i mean so that's
that is you know because we've discussed
making
essentially lambdas
with patterns and the point that nick is
making is that's completely unnecessary
because we basically already have it
yeah i would started using it all the
time
it's like instead of ifs i have replaces
everywhere
that's a good idea but but i mean but
should we
should we look at the
you know a failure case where should we
look at this
would that help in the code you write
yeah i think so so either failure or
missing that would be very helpful
then is the idea also that there'd be a
function like down values but it would
return
you know it would return versions where
the left-hand sides were somehow
transformed
well the issue is that
yeah i mean
i i guess the left-hand sides have to be
transformed to be some sort of pattern
sequence things right because if you
take the f away
you know it might take multiple
arguments i'm not sure what happens if
you if you say um
you know replace of a use the operator
form of replace on a sequence
and then the left-hand side of the rule
is a pattern sequence
okay so let's say
i mean this case here arrow
f of x x let's say
and then we apply that to i can't
imagine this will work
maybe it should though maybe it should
work maybe i'm not sure well i'm not
yeah i mean because it can't work and
replace because replace takes other art
obviously right but it could work in the
operator form i think we just didn't
think of this
i think this could work
is there is there any way of of writing
some i'm just thinking if there's any
rapper i mean replay pattern sequence is
not right because uh that's for patterns
not you know for values that you're
replacing
is there any other wrapper that you
could put around the things in the
argument slot the 789
to sort of group them into one thing
why do you need to i'm sorry why why
does that i'm not sure well i'm not sure
you do i'm just i'm just wondering i
mean if there's some like yeah we could
add support for this sort of uh taking a
sequence in the operator form of replace
but the question is if you were even
using the normal version of replace is
there some way that you could feed it a
sequence
to replace
you know what's interesting i mean jose
we're thinking about
um
we don't support vector functions or you
know like your functions of matrices and
other structures basically
sometimes you want it flat sometimes you
want the structure
and so the question is bridging between
the two
and this seems very similar to that
problem like i want to hold on to it
yes
in some container
um yes but then i want the container to
melt under certain circumstances yes
exactly well right that's the problem
look that's the problem of sequence
that's the problem of the thing that was
called null projection smp
that you know these things that i've
always hated because it's like you never
know when it's going to melt
and that's what's nice about nothing and
splice and so on
is that they're very well defined they
only melt
when they're inside a list
i mean
um
go ahead
there's like one example i've posted a
very amusing one of when this can go
wrong
what the heck is that
what
it seems like a bug
this
is x defined somewhere where'd the one
come from
let's check
uh no
try to understand this piece of code
okay i'm going to i'm going to turn that
into of b just so it helps me understand
it if you get rid of the the x
colon well i didn't even know you could
put
i didn't even know you looked the same
thing in a new kernel
right and what's happened here is that
it bound the x
even though it had nothing to bind it to
well yeah i mean i
does it ever make sense to bind a
pattern variable inside of an except
like what does that even mean
because the point is that the thing
doesn't match
right
so if you said if you said um match any
anything you know
except of x co you know x underscore
integer
right
yep then x could be any integer
yeah so it has no idea what to bind to
it
so it right so that should be an error i
think that's the the problem here
nick do you think it's anything other
than a bug
if you could just return missing or
something if you if you have a version
of replacement
the replacement can happen
and return mission of failure then this
is the example and this also should
happen
well i don't think it's your turn i'm
missing i mean i think it's just it's
just this is a malformed pattern
right
right what should happen is that the x
should turn red inside here probably
yeah and it should it should
yeah like it doesn't know whether it's
read or not
and until it applies to something
doesn't it i mean no it does because
it's i don't think
i mean the point is if you said it don't
work inside except the problem is that
you use it on the right hand side when
it's bound inside an acceptor you can
perfectly apply it to a there
the way i would read these is that x is
a
and then this should match anything
which is not a and b convert it into
x which is a
so return a
right but see this this doesn't make
sense either because it's the pattern
shouldn't be applying
right or no no no replacement is
happening in this case here because the
accept fail
right
right so that's what's happening in this
case it's not that it's not that it's
actually performing a replacement
right so the problem is that match queue
okay so here's the problem
there's another problem of this kind
which i remember showed up in 1987 when
we were writing um
black is it it's it's the case where
what is it it's a case where there's an
optional see the issue is okay the
question is can the binding of a
variable affect the matching of things
so for example if we say match queue
a
accept a
it'll say false okay if we say here
accept b it'll say true
right now the question is let's say we
simply add the annotation x colon in
here you would not expect that to affect
the matching
the fact that ex i i might because again
there's no like i think that when you
ask for like i don't think except the
pattern inside of accept is not
like
there there is no
val like for other patterns other than
accept maybe there are other you know
similar cases but but almost every other
pattern there's a thing that it sort of
clicks onto but the the argument of
accept doesn't click onto anything right
it's just saying
you know it's saying that this doesn't
click on anywhere and so if you say
something like x underscore integer in
an accept you know it it just means any
integer x is bound to any
integer like i don't think it means
anything to bind a variable x is not but
it isn't but it isn't in fact an integer
you're just saying the expression
doesn't match x bound to an integer
right but then the point is
but then the point is is that i think if
you use x anywhere right outside of the
accept right then then it's meaningless
i mean i i it is true though that if you
use the accepted multiple sorry if you
use the x a couple of places inside of
the excess that should be fine
right it's just if you use the if you
then take the x outside of the accept
that doesn't make any sense
but so but maybe actually sorry
uh one other case let me think if this
makes sense what if you have a
right what if you have uh an x that
appears somewhere on the left hand side
of the rule and then also appears
somewhere in the
on the left-hand side of the wall yeah
right and so i think you can get cases
where you bind the thing outside
and then the question is is there a
consistent binding of the x inside
and they can you know it can be yes
there is no there isn't look i think
there's a thing that should be done with
syntax coloring here
i mean this is really it kind of sounds
like it kind of sounds like the the the
case
the cases where it doesn't work i mean
it's basically it's some it's a fairly
complicated case that you might not be
able to catch with the syntax
highlighting stuff i mean
it sounds like and maybe you think about
this more it's basically uh
when when the only place that you could
figure out the value of x
is inside of this except right that's
the only uh
place where it's bound
yeah then then it then it won't work you
know this is very reminiscent there was
a bug that was one of our longest
running oldest bugs
that is a pattern matching bug that is
exactly like this but it was before we
had except
it's a it's a i'm trying to remember
what it is does anybody perhaps remember
um
it's a bug is this the single longest
running bug although it turned out it
was fixed in like version four or
something
i think it might have been yes it was
the thing but but then no no there was
an issue like this
where
i think we eventually decided to simply
not have it match
because it was a case where there was a
thing in there but it couldn't be bound
and the question is can the inability to
bind affect the matching
that's the question should should the
inability to bind affect whether the
match can take place
and because that's what it has to do
here otherwise otherwise this thing is
going to get tangled up
well either that or it has to have a
generic i was unbound
you know
you know it's either should the
inability to bind
affect the match or should
i mean or should it
return
some kind of unique
okay so i'm going to make a claim
um
unique uuid object i'm going to make a
claim that this is just like
an escaped module variable
do we believe that claim by inability do
you mean like you use the same symbol
multiple times but you can't find a
consistent binding or just no i mean
this case here i mean i mean no i mean
this case here where there's no
where it simply doesn't have a thing
and the point is that most of the time
when you bind a variable
you know
with the pattern matcher it's that you
have some input expression and that you
know and then that variable you know is
sort of clicking on to a piece of that
input expression
but with things like accept and maybe
some other cases
you know there is no
you're not asking it to click onto any
part of the input expression and so it's
just kind of floating in space
right i guess the problem is that the
pattern matched but not all of the
variables could be filled
exactly but but you see i claim that
that's extremely like
you know hypograph rewriting rule where
one of the things on the right hand side
didn't appear on the left well wait wait
hold hold on what what happens if you
use like alternatives or something like
that and and just do this say like you
know x underscore integer or you know
alternative uh y underscore real
and then replace that with x comma y
and then and then see what see what
happens
funky funky funky funky all right let's
see what it does what
this is the behavior of
repeated and repeated null
which i use sometimes
you need to hold complete probably if
anything is going to work at all you
need to hold complete because it's
turning into sequence open close
okay it got it got it this is exactly
like what
does
a repeated null is supposed to well
repeated null is supposed to uh you know
it has the option of matching nothing i
mean it's a triple underscore right
i mean the point is with a blank you
expect there to be exactly one thing
i don't understand the civil
i think this is related to the the i
mean why why is being bound to sequence
open close i think what's happening here
but the sequence is being kind of uh
yeah it's like how mr evaporating
yeah
i mean hold complete is a sequence hold
function right yes but it didn't get it
so right so i think it's being replaced
out too quickly
yeah well i mean this is the question of
should things
see
yeah this is a good argument for not
making things not match when you can't
bind things because otherwise this
wouldn't match at all
right but then but then the question is
in the case with accept does that mean x
should be bound to sequence open close
that's so freaking weird but perhaps so
i claim that it should actually be bound
to a module variable
i i don't think that makes any sense
that's that's
that's very weird i mean you're just
thinking about you know
okay i'm thinking about i'm thinking
about making space in physics but no but
i'm i'm thinking about the reason i'm
thinking that is that if you have this
result okay so let me show you an
example i mean i think it's just it's
both confusing nor it's neither con it's
neither understandable nor useful right
one of the problems here's one of the
problems that we're going to get into
is that really what we want
and the only way to avoid that yeah go
ahead i i think that's kind of like
that's kind of like saying you know i
did i
i did plot of two you know equals like
it's like saying import of some broken
string equals import of some other
broken string both the return dollar
failed but it says that they're equal
it's sort of like okay you know both of
them failed yes
but
but actually maybe just sorry one quick
thing with the alternatives could you
try just modifying the thing below to
just say arrow y just so you can see
don't wrap any like just on the right
hand side just write y because then
you'll see the sequence open close
there you go
magnificent
that's really weird
okay i mean
another way i think it's really nice
that it doesn't make an explicit
sequence
because i use this
when i'm passing things into things that
may potentially be sequence hold and i
don't want sequences i just want there
to not be anything
what happens with like if you have
something matching a triple underscore
and you pass it into hold complete it it
doesn't have a sequence there right
like it it evaporates the sequence
immediately it doesn't the whole
complete can't catch the sequence
well that's you know this is the this is
the problem it's like quotes right this
is this is
you know
the the incredibly high temperature
melting of sequence so to speak
um
okay we're going to have like this
sequence to make sense if you draw
parallels between patterns and logic
sequences like false
where your just blank is like true
because everything can match it and
nothing can match sequence
and also accept
acceptable concept of underscore i'm not
i think i think things can match
sequence like you know sequence pattern
open closed can that or pattern sequence
open closed can match sequence can't it
or even
a triple underscore
if you have alternatives in sequence
right it just makes it
it's the same as
except blank
empty alternatives it's like
except black
okay so your claim is that true is like
blank
and false is like except blank
but you're also claiming
that um sequence open close is somehow
like false
because accept blank is like empty
alternatives
and
alternatives of sequence
well is it is this is a de morgan's law
thing i mean where you're saying that if
empty alternatives
what that that matches
nothing and so then the
what is it the empty and has to match
everything or something i'm not sure
what the and would be
so this your claim is
this matches this will match nothing
yeah i mean
if
yeah which is its own
i think there are other logics where
that you know does match things but but
people don't use me very much wait wait
wait wait wait does it require laura
excluded middle to have that match no no
it's not obviously middle it's just that
there's some logics where um you know
basically the existential quantifier
over over nothing
uh you know returns uh what true
i think yeah true is the unusual thing
for it to return right
yes
so
we have this problem too in intersection
bracket bracket which represents a whole
universe and so we don't have a
representation for that
that's interesting
um
i think it's fair for it to fit we're
just union open close return empty list
i'm sure it does
yes it does wow okay
um
that's an interesting problem so i mean
that's similar to
sorry would this would be an insane
thing to introduce but you could have
something where uh intersection open
close sits unevaluated but then you know
functions like union if you do a union
of an intersection open close with or
sorry if you do a let's say an
intersection of intersection open close
with like the list one two
then it would just return the list one
two because it treats intersection open
close this symbolic representation of
everything right that seems like a very
bad idea there's lots of universal set
problems and
yeah right well i mean this is like
infinity that would be this would be the
analog of infinity for sense
i mean like it's not even like that
there's a russell's paradox maybe and
yeah i feel like this is very doomed you
know member q always returns true on
that object or something
it probably happens because intersection
is flat
oh if you run into can you try it please
yeah just
intersection of it remember q won't work
on it so that won't
uh what did it do i mean did it know
that that intersection flat so so then
the first intersection disappeared
oh
[Music]
that's cool okay
but if you used another set you know if
you used complement with it then it
wouldn't work
right if we said the complement of this
with that that's no way you need that to
be in the second argument or further you
can't have that in the first argument
because in the compliment
well no that's the infinite that's an
infinite set
yeah but i mean if you okay
yes for the consequence of one two
everything then you expect the list one
two but it's not going to work so which
is which is fine
yeah
um okay we just looking at a couple of
comments in our local chat here
um everybody is too used to we have
richard here who's joined us for many
live streams on the on the outside world
so
um
and uh
is used to chat only but but uh
um
let's see what was this branch of grass
depending on foliations yeah well we
don't have a way to specify foliations
guys i mean this is the problem coming
back to this question about evaluation
orders we have traversal order but we
don't have a more general way in a graph
for breadth first search all we have
is
i mean we don't have a way to specify
what the sequence of anti-chains so to
speak in our post set should be
there are many choices of possible
sequences of anti-chains which one do we
want to use
um
and i don't i just don't know any
formalism that even talks about that
does anybody know any formalism that
talks about that question
and our physics project doesn't count
but you know descriptions of sequences
of anti-chains
is there a category theory way of
thinking about that
anybody is anybody
okay blank on that um
richard is commenting about what unifi
should do um
which
is up here where we're talking about
unify
well we can put it down at the bottom
here
that example is interesting because you
you have to sort of
apply until fixed point
the result that i gave as an example if
you apply those to
both arguments of unify you end up with
matching
matching arguments
so wait a minute you're claiming this
can't be done in one shot you have to go
that's right yeah
you can try it it's like
i have a function that does this it's
not unified but unifier
and if i just goes in one direction
which which order should i do these
arguments then it doesn't matter
seems right
so we're in it but this is giving a
different answer
yeah it's it's it's
it's already substituting it's
equivalent but it's already substituting
the y into the into the z
uh result there so it should just leave
that
yeah it's not like minimal but it's it's
close enough i think
but which one is correct i mean the y
blank
could the y blank be anything no i see
the white like is jfw
no i understand but the y blank could be
in richard's version the y blank has not
been substituted but here
because because you're saying you could
have this in a form where you were
imagining that this association gets
repeatedly applied to determine what
happens
which is what nick has done
nick is as much as much as possible
resolve this so to speak
yeah my point is if you apply this
result to both of those expressions that
would they would produce the same result
okay
let's try it
okay so you're saying
replace oh
that's why i should have been doing this
okay so then this is this unifier here
should be that
okay oh my gosh and then you're saying
if i take that
very good
but you're saying okay is this like
solving an equation i mean are there
multiple solutions that work
i guess so
so for example if we if we had richard's
version
here
so let's say we say in this instead of
this we have y blank here
um checked only back
g of z blank
g of z blank is that right is that what
you
that's correct yeah
okay so now
we take this
get that
and now we take this
aha
it's not the same
maybe the boys repeated that was the
point
that's correct yeah replace until fixed
point yeah
i know i have to do that here as well
oh wow
oh my gosh
well that's interesting
okay so is there a well-defined notion
of so
if you
is there a well-defined notion of
one-shot unifier versus fixed-point
unifier
in other words is the is the one-shot
unifier well-defined or is it something
which where the only thing we can say is
that if we keep doing it
it will
always resolve to the same thing in
other words is this like you know a
confluence property for term rewriting
i bet it is
i bet that i bet the only thing you can
say for sure
is that um
uh
yeah
um
let's see richard had another comment
here about iterative deepening a star is
a case where revisitation
occurs oh wait a minute is this relevant
did you just um
you just put
those are separate sorry yeah okay
yeah yeah but they're still relevant to
our discussion i think
by jungle evaluation
what the heck is this
a jungle morphism
that is even a scary concept what on
earth is this
what is a jungle
well in the abstract they define it as
an acyclic hypergraph uh represents a
set of terms such that common subterms
can be shared
so it's this whole sort of term graph
subsuming
term you know story but uh
it seems to be evolved in involved in
sort of efficiency of
termi writing systems yeah
okay
and this is a tree traversal
via attribute grammar story
what does that mean
so you're saying
where is the attribute grammar living
does it live is it living on the tree
and then you're saying
which way to traverse based on content
on the tree is that the idea
do we think
i i think this is this is something
where it matters what's in the tree how
you traverse it
if i'm not mistaken isn't that what an
attribute grammar
does yeah i think that's that's what
this is doing yeah it's like a
controlled evaluation yeah so it's it's
with this sort of dynamic evaluation
order question yeah
right right right so this is this is
attribute grammars are related to
treefold
yes i think that's right
right so this is
determining
tree traversal
by tree content
well that was dags actually
was that dags or trees i don't remember
here
generalizing from trees to dags
and both papers refer to this uh you
know sub-expression sharing
aspect
right which is what
i mean that's the main reason people
want to use these dags is that like like
for the combinators thing
sharing you know doing combinators with
dags was dramatically more efficient
um
okay
uh anyway what was the comment about
about a star
uh so that was like if you have a
i mean we speak about computationally
bounded observers but one aspect of that
would be say memory bounded so you only
have a sort of finite scratch space to
think about your your states okay and
and so that's a case which occurs in
sort of classical search or you know
search from classical ai where
one wants to sort of find the the lowest
cost path and in order to do so you have
to sort of revisit nodes and sort of
expand
expand the search tree sort of
non-uniformly
that's what you're saying so it's like
it's like a stack it's a bit like a
stack having a bounded stack or
something
with which to
that's an interesting question as well i
mean they okay that's an interesting
observer theory question of um uh
bounded computation
slash memory
for observer theory so so one question
would be
um you know what kind of recursion can
you do with a bounded stack
because if you're doing
depth first search
if i'm not mistaken right you have to
have an unbounded depth of stack
and this is why ida star was sort of
introduced because it uh
yeah i mean the yeah solves that problem
of
uh running out of memory because you
keep having to yeah
what is ideas
what is that
idea star is uh iterative deepening a
star it's a graph traversal path search
algorithm
and it's a variant on on a star search
and so so that
i see so that's a thing and that's
probably what that paper was was
something about the sharing the pain
thing i would guess is something not
unrelated to this as well because it's
kind of asking the question
because you have a
right you have a stack depth
as i haven't thought about that i mean
in other words you have
and this relates also ian to your
tree traversal business
in tree traversal
you are
uh
let's see i mean
you're if you do breadth first tree
traversal
you don't need
a deep stack right you just have
i'm not wrong right you you're just
doing it's a very shallow stack
can we can we if if we do
um
is there a way of seeing the stack with
the trees you'll bottom up breadth first
then that's not the case
no if it's bottom up top down bread
first yeah
right but can we see the stack is there
a way to use tree fold or something to
see the stack
can we can we okay here's an exercise
given a tree
label every node by the state of the
stack when you visited that node
i could put something together i don't i
don't think it's particularly easy with
top level functions
okay are we interesting to see because
that's the i just hadn't thought of this
um
okay so these things involve like
multiple like stacks and queues
what do you mean so so richard is
quoting something here about a star
keeps a large queue of unexplored nodes
that can quickly fill up memory
ida star does not remember any node
except the ones on the current path
requires an amount of memory that is
only linear in the length of the
solution it constructs
okay
this is a good idea which had not
occurred to me for the for the whole um
observer
yeah i mean that that really is the
question of does the observer know where
they are
you know how how how much information
does the observer have you know stack
depth
is um
is like asking
um you know how much
information
about their location
does the observer keep
so in other words it's like it's like
it's like um uh
you know theseus and ariadne and the
minotaur and pieces of string and so on
it's like do they just
does theseus just remember
was theseus wasn't it
i'm not i'm thinking only about his ship
but but you know when theseus is going
around the labyrinth does he remember
only you know what turns he made or does
he maintain a piece of string that meant
that keeps information about what the
sequence of turns was
um
that's perhaps not a useful analogy
um
well okay we we have run out of time
here and actually the meeting that we
are doing next i think has a rather
overlapping set of people and maybe we
should just stay on the same
um
uh well maybe not what what is the next
meeting it's about expression trees
right that ian that's your meeting right
can we do you have an agenda or
something did you send it through
because we could just bring it up here
and just see whether that's how
overlapping with this it actually is
um
i just sent it to you okay great
um
is this is this not very overlapping or
is it
i i i don't think it touches on anything
that we're discussing in
multi-computation okay all right fine
fine fine fine all right then we'll make
a separate meeting okay well look guys i
mean on this
wow this is a complicated area um
roger do you have any wisdom about any
of this
i think roger already left up up oh well
then then he's like the accept he's like
the the bound variable and they accept
um
okay and i mean
we will need to continue this i mean
it's going to take
it looks like
you know probably what we should try to
i'm still a little bit unclear you know
that there's still many different
threads here that need to be pulled
together
um
and you know nick seems to have some
great functions that are starting to
take shape here
um and i just i want to make sure that
we understand so for example having the
thing that is the future of find
equation or proof that has a different
form of output
that is
you know where you can take the output
from find equational proof and actually
sort of execute those transformations
that's clearly useful and seeming to me
like we need to have a design
where there are
on the order of ten functions
that include things like find the
branchial graph of a good given graph
find these unifiers
all these kinds of things we're going to
need a bunch of these functions
um and you know we should basically plan
on trying to design on the order of that
many functions
um i'm i'm just not
confident yet about how we deal with
this
i mean it really relates to this
observer theory foliations business etc
um
anyway uh well this was interesting i
thought at least
um
so
thanks to everyone here and um
uh thanks to um
uh
um
some comments on our live stream here
and um i guess we're going to we'll
we'll be live streaming the next meeting
as well
but uh
see you all soon